how are you sir okay thank you Jim and
Sam could go Sam and Jim Sam is better
we have to get mics for you guys - we
didn't know everybody was coming until
today they didn't tell us that exactly
my mic zac amico from the underground
movie to the underground train t-shirt
portland star of return to return to new
comer a kilocalorie to what mike is what
mike is sick and then I turn down a
little bit these two loud as it is know
all the mics run alright this is amazing
we're on the catherine corcoran just
came fresh from the subway and yes
mister second ito the star of return to
with its jim i can't as i live in as
women breathe there you go while
catherine is getting set up - you know
it's Oscar even though this is all about
return to return return to my aka volume
to write a Catherine Zack and I would
like to present you gentlemen with oh
he's ducking under the table right in
front of me you know everybody yeah this
poultry guys night of the chicken dead
the original posters the theatrical /
world very rare and very hard to find
yeah that's my foul movement and as if
that get it foul more blow jobs
I love Lloyd Kaufman word amazing poetry
guys DVDs for both of you thanks Thank
You Larry guy and this is one of the
Troma classics it's a musical and not
only that but there's a 800 page novel
that goes with it that believe Random
House published thank you well
yeah yeah I'm not seeing ran okay but
I'll take your word for it would be wind
Paulding house and we got stick okay yes
for your card I love Tromaville high
school how did she say mother's trauma
is that my kick that yeah it was on a
minute ago and then you turn it on no I
didn't turn off the top before we get
any further I would like to congratulate
I would like to congratulate dicks and
I'd like to say dick on radio as many
times I can't Dick's Sporting Goods is
no longer going to be selling guns
that's the throw weapons so I will be
shopping at Dick's even though I hate
time I buy a gun there no assault guns
other guns okay
Dick's Sporting Goods they said today is
no longer selling assault
we went from chicks chicks poultry guys
to dicks and we can combine them we have
true love right
[Laughter]
Oh Jim I'm doing good man doing I
realize podcast with Louis J Gomez is
that you and him together yeah it's me
and him together on a gas digital say my
network is legions ganks I see um
dividers and you've got the other thing
you just mentioned yes tom is a guy
that's and what was the other thing you
said gas digital network gas yes of
course burritos in the subway yeah you
were you always do in the bill has
podcast
yeah me and Lewis I'm doing the show for
about four years now okay I didn't know
that was just you and him yeah that's
our that's our hetero life mate
relationship you should do the check
podcast again people loved you oh I
would love to hear me
big deal you ever hear the history
hyenas favorite voice yeah hyena gallery
in Burbank is doing a return to return
to Newcomb hi I am two art show all
tributed to Zack and Catherine's
movie so heam entire gallery of hyena
gallery in Burbank the reception is the
7th of March but some of the art will be
in the Laemmle theatres
in there
that's right that's right maked pictures
of me so that other people wouldn't
bother they're like big prints of me
naked from the movie and my dad bought
both and gave them to me so that
strangers wouldn't buy them they took my
totally nude yes dick showing yes
is it a flattering shot those don't
exist feel about because I would imagine
it first they're probably very excited
you do you're doing film work with Troma
films that's a big deal and then they
find out about the nude scenes how they
learned my dad I said I streaked in the
movie right not know him not know he
just saw him naked for like a half an
hour my mom takes many shots of return
to return to Newcombe iak volume 2 is is
many many dicks not one sells an assault
weapon thank you for pointing that like
it's a selling point a lot of Bailey J
is in it so she really yeah I haven't
seen what Bailey J where she slaps me oh
why she dressed yeah that's better I had
to do about 30 feet well what I wanted
yeah did you want Bailey to slap you
more than anything in the world I could
have cut glass with my heart are you
like do you like being slapped oh yeah
absolutely
I've got a little bit of the humiliation
stuff but I'm not a whole fan of it do
you like being beaten up or just slapped
it occurs sometimes oh wow it looks like
barely J yeah I knew you liked
humiliation try to open a Troma movie in
Los Angeles you Jim and Sam are the only
you know I've been doing this for 50
years right New York not one New York
publication covers the fact that Troma
is the oldest over 40 years old no major
other than Chris Nicholas which is
probably thanks to Zach D'Amico
well you're underground that's what it
is you're kind of Jericho Jericho so
what they day every New York Times every
two minutes they've got a full page
answer somebody with your arms and legs
or deep underground you want them to be
well I'm not commenting you should be
though I'm just saying that's why it is
though I like the mainstream successes
that have come out of Troma that's true
I mean you're talking the first person
who would even distribute Trey Parker
and
films James Gunn Quentin Tarantino even
cites him as an inspiration uses some of
his you know yeah it does kind of suck
when the guy behind so much of it
doesn't get the credit that everybody
who kind of comes out of it but you look
at Robert Townsend there's an example of
a guy who helped break Damon Wayans and
I think he knew all these people that he
was responsible for showcasing but
they're black people you know attaboy
good point recently the New York Times
didn't cover any of that but you know
but like Robert Townsend never gets to
use talent people don't talk about
Robert Townsend they just talk about all
the people he kind of discovered I mean
Chris do you know good Lloyd Kaufman and
Troma films this is where not only
poultrygeist night of the chicken dead
came from right but you're talking about
cannibal the musical you're talking
about Romeo and Juliet the toxic avenger
yeah Nukem high class of nuke oh my
return to Nukem high and now return to
return to Nukem high AKA volume 2 which
I believe is opening in LA March 8th
Philadelphia tomorrow night yeah that's
right tomorrow night and Philadelphia to
a short live yeah you go all you want to
a screening yeah so what do you do after
the screenings you do meet I like like
question Q and I are you just [ __ ]
hang out usually Lloyd does a Q&A and
the cast will be up there with them and
then with our group of people we usually
throw a karaoke party after oh you do so
we uh we have all the fans come wherever
we are we have a big party it's going to
be if some of the bands are playing at
the after-party yeah I think we have
bands right yeah the Eels I think so
will you sing a Carrie yes exactly and
she probably singular not plural they're
all dead
so come on you doing wise you're doing
great wait that's premiering what's it
called what's it return to return to
Newcomb hi aka volume 2 but I've known
Zac and Katherine for five or six years
and these all see these are stars of the
things you know Fergie started with us I
would say zac amico is the next Fergie
and the Katherine would be the next
James Garner
but these two people I've seen Zach's a
comedy a develop over the past six years
and actually he is getting funnier and
they say it takes ten years that right
yeah I say Zach is already there after
only five years do they ever come back
though these big stars ever come back
like you know when they want and they
get hugely famous never come back into a
film for you
they look if you had to sleep on the
floor for two months and learn how to
defecate in a paper bag I don't think
you would be coming back fair enough
shut up I can't have an offer just today
for from James Gunn to be in a movie
he's producing in Atlanta so are you
taking it I thinking about it in the
salmon Jim come on you don't stand up
this is gonna be eight years from oh
okay you're doing that's good yeah yeah
and you're still doing the roast ya do
ya I love ya I battled Rosebud Baker
about two weeks ago I was my favorite
one I've ever done who's that a real
funny girl uh date Seton Smith oh okay
now is Seton there no Seton was not
there does he like is it hard for him to
watch his girlfriend get like murder on
stage a lot of significant others have
issues with it yeah I mean it would be
hard to watch your girlfriend in salted
you know or trashed I'm sure girlfriends
don't care about their boyfriend getting
trashed no they look the girls always
love it the guys usually it's I think
it's just an ego thing sure that the
best person or like when you're going
head-to-head with an attractive female
is that like the best position you could
be in as a roaster
when you as a guy who say the doggy
style position is positive position
norton talking you have to really really
beat her because the crowds always gonna
be on her side right because i'm so dark
yeah but you were also I mean a hot girl
they would probably see you as you know
I did striking back right you would
think that
yeah I've been talking about their dead
sister then they they want to see me get
rekt I see but you had a couple of rows
static got like millions and millions of
views of you when you you destroyed some
wow that's great could there's something
about watching a pretty girl get
insulted by a guy that they kind of like
it's also like that video isn't the most
flattering title if I remember what is
directly it's not like you know comic
genius zac amico it started as nerdy
comedian roasts hot chick yeah and then
after being online for three days slowly
the website started changing it to like
fat slob she was a funny roaster to her
and Luis roasted each other I thought
she was good I mean she's she's a good
roaster so yeah she's great she's just
had a bad night yeah speaking of
Roosters you know the poultry guys
people have wanted to remake speaking of
roosters a poultry guys and whenever we
make poultry people in City of Angels
really are good enough
chicken feet rates Jim I know I know I
just I just rely on word of mouth I just
wanted to get on to Cathy get off the
sack thing but he was in the subway got
late in the subway so he was tardy no
but you're a beautiful woman
you should be roasting Zach Catherine
you in a movie would leave somebody
rather write a very good boxing movie
Liev Schreiber bleed I think raging what
Chuck Wepner yes oh you are I've heard
of that movie I haven't seen it it's his
life and tells what actually happened
that inspired who do you play I play one
of his various mistresses Oh - Chuck
Chuck [ __ ] a lot of girls huh